[Music]
when I was a kid when I was in Middle
School and High School I remember
watching Viva La Bam and just if you
ever want to be bam that everybody
wanted to be that guy because he was a
good looking dude had a ton of money
destruct just like a professional
skateboarder traveled the world seemed
just like the coolest guy in the world
yeah and um did you ever attempt any
stunts to be like bam uh no I knew
better I knew better for sure uh but it
is also funny how your how your sense of
humor changes because as as a kid when
we first saw jackass and they're doing
the shopping cart stuff yeah that was
like the Pinnacle of Comedy it was
hysterical just now I watch that and I
it makes me hurt because I'm like oh
that looks painful yeah or just any of
the any of the um
any of the movies now you watch and it
hurts as as an older person yeah dude
because you can contextualize pain yes
you can get when you're a [__] kid
nothing hurts yeah and you're oh I slay
my skull on the pavement I just stood up
and I was like I think I'm fine
you're not me man I I never did anything
remotely dangerous I I have a
my self-preservation Gene is powerful
okay
yeah although my uh one of my good
friends whose birthday is today actually
he's a one of the smartest guys I know
and we were both very smart kids in high
school but uh we thought that it would
be funny to randomly surprise one
another by punching each other in the
back of the head yeah as hard as we
could yeah
I'd be standing there and all of a
sudden I just feel uh just getting
rocked in the back of the head and he'd
be like oh my God and he was like a
full-on top of his class he's an
accountant now
um yeah I'm surprised both of you can
still like walk and like feed yourselves
after that I remember one time he jumped
off of a bench and down onto me and yeah
it was uh
yeah it hurt back of the head is like
dangerous yeah it's like the most
insanely dude oh my God
as hard as you could
yeah pretty hard good thing you guys
were kids and you didn't know how to
really generate power I mean we're like
juniors in high school yeah but like but
that's pretty old like no I'm not I'm
not undermining it I know that [__] hurt
but I'm saying like thank God you
weren't like
full-on adult men adult men that like
knew how to use like their body weight
yeah yeah oh yeah I could I could
probably kill someone with one punch you
think so yeah
oh yeah laugh it up oh you don't believe
me no no don't don't [__] you don't
believe me don't make Ben feel crazy I
I'm sure there's a 75 year old well
because you
if you were to give me if if
anyway I feel like anybody could kill
someone with one punch you hit him in
the back of the head or you hit him in
the chin the right way or are they you
know they fall over and [__] oh there's
that that's why I don't want to get in
any fights I don't uh you know I don't
trust my own power
I don't wanna I don't want to go to
prison man yeah dude
truly straight up no cap No Cap no no
hat there man yeah if you had one you
one punch and you had to kill somebody
who would it be no where would you hit
him
if I had one punch and I had to kill
them
I could go Harry Houdini so thank you
very much is that me is that Me Shaggy
kills your boyfriend outside the bar uh
that'll teach you to mess with school
very good stay away from my Scooby
Snacks
uh if I had to kill someone with one
punch
where'd you hit him I wouldn't go if it
were a small woman
that's a good place to start man that's
a great place to start
well because you know people come in all
sorts of shapes and sizes you're you're
five foot X is hearing this right now
being like think [__]
uh well because Harry Houdini died from
getting punched in the stomach oh is
that how he died yeah who punched him uh
some kid some college kid
asked him if he could because at the
time I believe Houdini had a trick where
he could take a punch in the stomach but
he could only do it when he was ready
for it and he was famously like laying
down and the kid came up and said hey
Houdini and just like slugged him in the
stomach killed him wow
um so yeah you could you could I know
like a heart punch could be very
devastating but I would have to I guess
I would have to go with like
a [__] uppercut
uppercut and then they they fall onto
the [__] floor that's hard to hit
yeah hitting the neck
yeah right see this is why you should
just shouldn't do it I was thinking yeah
when you're saying if you had to kill
someone I was thinking like there this
person's coming at you uh yeah so I
would probably I'd probably aim
to get a clean knockout
but if if you know if the goal is to get
them killed
the like loss of consciousness and like
hitting the pavement that might do it
yeah
if it was a fight to the death man yeah
honestly but your point I think is so
valid in that everyone
just don't get in a street fight ever
even if you're like you're equipped for
it just don't like as you see that you
saw that video that that MMA guy
knocking those two [__] out that just
kept trying to [__] with him I think so
either walking in the street and he
drops both of them and they keep like
trying to get back up and like get some
more
dude so dangerous for all of them
involved it's it's it blows my mind
how there are still videos that come out
from high schools Across America of kids
bullying yeah and kids
uh getting in fights and like knocking
guys out yeah because you would think
that the most online generation ever
would realize that bullying leads to
school shootings
and fighting like that leads to
potential [__] death when was the
last time you're around a 14 or 15 year
old that's the problem dude I was gonna
say like I think the problem with young
boys is not I shouldn't say the problem
I should say fundamentally I think young
boys are just like they're [__]
they're just battery packs like they
they just want to you know like there's
so much going on in their body sure I
think
most commonly it comes out in like you
know it's just like rough housing
whatever you want to call it like and
that's why like young guys get so
[__] physical with each other it's
because like they're just feeling a lot
of [__] and they don't know how to deal
um because you know my junior high in
high school I can't compare it to others
but in my memory it's like damn like
kids fought all the time so I think I
think sometimes like when you're
watching that show on your phone I feel
like you're a young dude like you're
probably getting charged up like
that could be me yeah
I got that out by doing stupid [__] with
my brothers like uh one of us getting in
the trunk of the car and just having the
other brother go over speed bumps
or we had this thing called Fast
driveway
where
my brother was just doing jackass yeah
yeah no we had a thing called Fast
driveway where uh he he would turn and
park in the driveway as fast as he could
without hitting the garage huh and it
was really fun because he just like rip
it going like 15 miles an hour up the
driveway and then just slam on the
blueprints rismo exercise it was so fun
stop inside the cones and every time try
this at home tonight and like run right
into there no I was listening to the TMG
podcast Minnesota shoot called Fast
driveway
well we had a little slogan for it it
was called we would say it's the fastest
way to get up a driveway
that's pretty smart yeah fast driveway
man Jesus Christ where does the time go
uh one thing we like to do also was
um
if I was driving say and My Brother Sam
was in the passenger seat I would roll
down my window and fully put my body out
uh out the window yeah but with my feet
still controlling the pedals yeah and he
he would he would uh turn the wheel for
like a turn so like we'd be taking him
right at it
my body would be fully out while he like
kind of pulls the wheel just because we
were like someone had to have seen that
and it's really funny to just see a
teenage boy hanging out the uh driver's
side are you saying you had too much
common sense to do jackass stuff yeah
you're doing [__] at high speed brother
well that's more um that's more the
thinking man's jackass yeah sure because
it's it's not putting well it is putting
ourselves in danger putting like
hundreds of people at danger yeah way
more giving the bystander something to
head scratcher right what the [__] did I
just see you know yeah that was good oh
those were good times yeah one of my
favorite driving stunts was uh standing
up inside a Toyota 4Runner
and like I would um hold the oh [__]
handle with my left hand
and steer with my right and I would be
like fully standing up outside the
window while driving the car and this
would make my friends laugh
that's uh that was like original ghost
writing yeah
yeah I did that with my sunroof but
that's really I can still reach the
pedals and then stop as hard as you
could no I would just drive oh yeah sure
the another thing we would do is just
like straight up drive a hundred miles
an hour
yeah yeah
I wonder why young boys fight in high
school but at like [__] at like 3 P.M
on the freeway just like getting on
there was this one on-ramp that uh it
turned into its own lane and then within
a mile it was its own off-ramp so when
you got on you could just see clear
ahead of you and yeah sometimes he'd get
on and just say that what I just sorry I
didn't interrupt you again I just love
the way you said that just straight up
going 100 miles an hour
in a [__] 1990 Toyota Camry oh you're
asking for it you are [__] those are
small airbags bro they even deploy they
probably just shoot out holes dude
people oh man that's a generational
thing right there what I'm sure most
people understand like listening but I
think
uh particularly like like the cars in
the late 90s the [__] steering wheel
was like small as [__] so that airbag
was in like maybe like a Kleenex sized
box so when that [__] came out it
probably hurt oh yeah people break their
noses they break if you're if you have
your hand a certain way on the thing
they that's why they tell you ten and
two yeah so that if the airbag deploys
your hands shoot out not like into your
own face which happens that's why they
also tell you don't if you're a
passenger don't put your phone bro yeah
yeah your legs will shoot you'll get
your own knee in your face dude I
[__] people that drive like this oh
yeah I do that sometimes no no no like
foot on this oh oh I put my foot up on
the yeah
yeah that's asking for it your pretzel
mode yeah